pascal aussi c'est un mec comme je le
dis à chaque fois il suit les dossiers
il laisse pas les familles en détresse
il est tout le temps avec eux et il fait
un travail formidable et vous tout le
monde lui aussi à lui vraiment il fait
l'unanimité quand j'ai dit qu'à et
pascal ce soir tout le monde était
interdite dans ce fait abattre
chaque fois que tu viens ça cartonne
bâlois est plus souvent eh ben moi je
suis bien content mais alors je pourrais
prendre la place de l'art et jaloux
c'est la jalousie qui parle pas il était
jaloux de pascal il est beau parce
qu'elle a elle-même y allez quand même
vous allez bien je pense qu il aime bien
il aimait à dire que j'ai tu veux dire
bye-bye coutume elle m'a tout donné
qu'elle habitait lien intéressant de
connaître un peu plus à mascate pascal
et est beau parce qu'elle est beau très
beau sourire je me regarde moi j'adorais
le toit comme la musculation